foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
taking a deep dive into what could have
happened to The Wizarding World and the
lives of the witches and wizards we now
know so well if Golic Grindelwald had
been the winner of his Infamous duel
with Albus Dumbledore as many of you
will know in 1945 Albus Dumbledore at
long last challenged the dark wizard
Grindelwald defeating him in a jewel
which ended grindelwald's reign of
terror Over The Wizarding community and
put a stop to his frightful rise to
power this Jewel of course came decades
after the two men had formed an intense
bond in their youth in fact according to
Dumbledore's own admission Albus was in
fact in love with gallet as a Young Man
their relationship was initially built
upon a foundation of shared hatred
towards muggle kind and they dreamed of
a world in which witches and wizards
would conquer the non magical world and
make them into a subservient people
fortunately for the greater magical
community at large Albus Dumbledore's
reverie of this dystopian version of the
world was obliterated when his younger
sister Ariana was killed in a misguided
argument between himself gallant and
amberforth albus's younger brother
turned fatal after this tragic incident
the two young Wizards parted ways as
their ideologies began to diverge
drastically many years later Gellert
began his Infamous rise to power in
pursuit of making the world he'd once
envisioned alongside Dumbledore a
reality it's at this point in their
shared history that we discovered that
Grindelwald and Albus had made an
unbreakable vow with one another never
to oppose the other this was done at a
time when they both believed they wanted
the same thing domination over the human
race unfortunately this Val prevented
Dumbledore from putting a stop to all
the evil things Grindelwald did for
decades but as I mentioned at the start
of this video there eventually came a
time in which Albus was able to overcome
The Vow challenge Grindelwald and
ultimately defeat and imprison him the
question I raised with you now is what
would have happened if Alba Dumbledore
had not won this fight what would the
Wizarding World have looked like if the
winner had in fact been gallat
Grindelwald instead indeed there are
many number of questions at this
alteration to the Past brings about
first and foremost to any great fan of
Harry Potter anyway the question that
comes to mind is what would have
happened to the Great and Powerful Albus
Dumbledore
if Dumbledore had lost the jewel to
Grindelwald a dark and some may even say
monstrous wizard it's not too far out of
the realm of possibility to consider
that perhaps Gellert would have simply
killed Albus after all this would have
put an end to the only wizard who had
ever been powerful enough to be his
equal and for those of you who have
watched any of the Fantastic Beasts
films you know that Grindelwald
certainly wasn't averse to Casting fatal
spells when met with resistance or a
challenge however with Albers there is
the question of their love for one
another yes they no longer fundamentally
agreed with one another's views of the
world and they wanted completely
opposite things for the people who
populated the Earth but could
Grindelwald truly just erase his
feelings for Dumbledore I don't think so
and this leads me to believe that
Gallard wouldn't have killed Albus
there's also the possibility that
perhaps he couldn't if you think about
it we don't really know yet how
Dumbledore breaks the unbreakable vow
between the two wizards for bull we know
perhaps he was just able to weaken it to
the point that he was able to challenge
Gallup to a duel but not fully break it
to the point that he could take
grindelwald's life there's also the
possibility that if Grindelwald won the
jewel perhaps he would have spared
Dumbledore's life with the hope that
he'd be able to bring him back around to
their once shared life's purpose of
enslaving Muggles after all since
Grindelwald was the one breaking the law
he certainly wouldn't have handed
Dumbledore over to the authorities they
simply would have freed him since he had
gone up against Grindelwald with the
intention of stopping him from
terrorizing The Wizarding World so maybe
he would have kept him in captivity
slowly luring him back to joining him on
his Crusade of the greater good and if
he had held him in captivity for long
enough and Dumbledore's feelings still
burned even ever so slightly for
Grindelwald perhaps this plan just might
have worked this leads us to the
question of what would have happened to
Europe and the world as a whole now if
Gaelic Grindelwald had not been stopped
by Dumbledore in 1945 and he had instead
defeated Albus who later became known as
one of the greatest and most powerful
wizards of all time there likely
wouldn't have been anyone else to stand
in his way in fact if Grindelwald was
successful in swaying Dumbledore back
over to his anti-muggle views he would
have been seen as quite Unstoppable
Grindelwald and Dumbledore against the
world the world likely wouldn't have
stood a chance and so Gallatin Albus
would have led their followers or
acolytes as they were known across the
globe in their Crusade of the greater
good taking over civilization one
community at a time until eventually
they had control of the entire world
this new world would have been one in
which non-magical folks served their
more powerful magical Masters there
likely would have been distinct classes
of witches and wizards with those who
had opposed Grindelwald serving those
who had followed him and believed in his
vision I see it as somewhat of a caste
system a social stratification there
would have been pure blood to the top
who completely bought into the idea of
blood Purity and Muggles being less than
this group would have been the upper
class so to speak and would have been
given land wealth and power then there
would have been witches and wizards of
mixed blood who may not have been super
into the idea of blood Purity
considering their Heritage but who
definitely believed they were better
than Muggles this group would have been
a sort of middle class if you will they
wouldn't have been super rich and
Powerful but they had a bit of land and
were pretty much left alone by the pure
Bloods below this group of witches and
wizards would have been those who
opposed Grindelwald and his beliefs this
group would have been seen as the
absolute lowest class in society they
would have been quite poor although poor
witches and wizard is still a concept I
can't and they would have had very
limited Liberties for example I don't
believe they would have been allowed to
move about the world at their will
instead they would have been confined to
a region of grindelwald's choosing an
area of the globe in which he felt they
could do little harm or create any
resistance or Uprising against his rule
then of course there would have been the
Muggles in a reality in which
Grindelwald had defeated Dumbledore I
believe that all of the Muggles would
have been enslaved imprisoned or killed
for those who put up any sort of fight
at all it's not unrealistic to believe
that Gallard simply would have killed
them off that way they wouldn't have
been able to create any more trouble
down the line for the Muggles who
surrendered willingly I think he would
have imprisoned them from there he would
have had witches and wizards he trusted
watch over his muggle prisoners
requesting reports on which one seemed
amicable to the idea of serving magical
Masters after identifying Muggles who
are willing to be subservient these
people would have been placed in homes
of the pure blood acolyte families of
course the Muggles would have only been
trusted to Simply obey so a charm
similar to the magical contract put onto
househelves would have been placed onto
the Muggle servants muckles who remained
resistant would be left to live out
their lives in the magical prisons
created by Grindelwald orb killed off if
they made too much trouble within the
confines of their imprisonment now all
of this would have been the ideal
outcome for Grindelwald and the vision
he had once held for the world but what
would have happened if another wizard
with equally as dark but substantially
different interests came to power years
later of course I'm referring to the
rise of He Who Shall Not Be Named
Voldemort Howard Voldemort fit into this
version of reality there of course lies
the possibility that Voldemort may have
never existed should such a drastic
change in history have taken place since
it does seem unlikely that a pure blood
wedge like maripi gaunt would have been
able to have an affair with a muggle
such as Tom Riddle if Grindelwald had
ruled over the world however for
argument's sake let's say that Tom
Riddle was the servant of a pureblood
family which provided the merapi gaunt
access to him for similar reasons that
arise in a reality in which dumbled or
won the duel maripi gaunt would have had
to give up the baby to an orphanage this
means that little Tom's life would have
been just as damaging and difficult as
it had been in the reality of Harry
Potter that we know if not maybe even a
little harder perhaps the orphanage
would have known of his Heritage and
would have been abusive and
discriminatory of his mixed blood
background it's difficult to say whether
or not Grindelwald would have allowed a
mud blood like Tom Riddle into a School
of Witchcraft and was a tree such as
Hogwarts of course expectations would
been made for the middle class we
discussed earlier in the video since
their discrete would have been seen as
uneducated having taken place before
grindelwald's rise to power but it's
unclear whether or not mixed blooded
witches and wizards who were born after
gallup's rise to power would have been
allowed the same leniency this of course
leads us to the question of whether or
not young Tom Riddle would have become
as powerful as he did if he hadn't
attended Hogwarts would he have been
able to cultivate his magic outside of a
traditional education and if he hadn't
gone to Hogwarts would he have
discovered horcruxes and developed the
same plan to split his soul all of this
is hard to say due to his intensity as a
young boy however and his determination
as a youth I think it's rather likely
that Tom would have been able to develop
himself into some version of the
Voldemort that we know from the Harry
Potter series it's true that he may not
have received a formal education in
Magic but with someone like Tom's
proclivities towards dark magic it's not
hard to imagine that he may have been
able to acquire his learnings from a
less traditional Source I'm sure a
triple two down nocturnality would have
resulted in young Tom finding a dark
witch or wizard willing to overlook
Riddle's Heritage and take him under
their wing or knowing the Deep seated
devious nature of Tom perhaps he would
have just left his ancestry out of any
explanation of his identity entirely
all right so if Tom Riddle was able to
obtain the magical knowledge he required
to become the dark lord I believe that
he would have eventually risen to power
in a similar fashion as he did in the
actual series of course in this version
of reality there would have been one
major difference Voldemort and his Death
Eaters would have had one very large
rival gallit Grindelwald and his
acolytes not to mention grindelwald's
right-hand man Albus Dumbledore because
don't forget in this Theory Albus was
defeated by Gallard and persuaded to
rejoin his cause this also leads to the
question of how many of Voldemort would
be Death Eaters would have already been
pledged to Grindelwald as an acolyte
with the split of allegiances have
weakened either of these dark Wizards
power okay so let's imagine that the two
dark Wizards had equal followers at
their disposal what these two forces
have gone up against each other who
would have won or would Voldemort simply
have kept his evil reign confined to
Europe after all he never really
expressed much interest in expanding his
rule across the globe as Grindelwald did
in fact he seemed much more focused on
taking down Harry Potter than he did on
Conquering the entire Wizarding World in
contrast gellert's Vision was much
larger he wanted to enslave the world's
population of Muggles and force his way
of life onto all of civilization when
you look at it this way it doesn't seem
unreasonable to think that perhaps
Grindelwald may have made Voldemort one
of his most trusted officials perhaps
Voldemort would have been in charge of
managing The Wizarding Community as
Mughal population within the UK after
all both Wizards were obsessed with
blood Purity and ruling over those who
they saw as inferior the only flaw in
this theory is that Voldemort was not of
pure-blooded lineage it remains to be
seen whether or not his allegiance to
the cause and inclination for violence
and dark magic would have been enough
for Grindelwald to forget vold the most
Heritage assuming that gallit could
Overlook Voldemort's ancestry I would
think that Voldemort may have still
ended up being called the dark lord in
which case I think Grindelwald may have
wanted to one-up him and go by something
that would outrank Lord would you agree
that it's rather amusing to think that
perhaps in a fit of jealousy over the
Loyalty his underling received from his
region that Grindelwald may have decided
to call himself the dark King which
indeed brings us to our next query would
Grindelwald have been Supreme mugwump
for those of you who have seen the most
recent Fantastic Beasts film you'll know
that the Supreme magwump was the elected
chairman of the international
Confederation of wizards this was a
position that gelik Grindelwald wished
to occupy in Fantastic Beasts the
secrets of Dumbledore in the movie The
History of the selected role is revealed
explaining how in ancient times the
chairman was chosen by a magical
creature called a chilling in a ceremony
known as the Walk of the Chillin during
this ceremony a Chillin which The
Wizarding World believed to be the
purest magical creature in existence one
who could identify purity of heart just
by looking at a witch or wizard would
assess the candidates and select the
person they deemed worthy of the role as
time went on this tradition disappeared
and the chairman was instead elected by
a majority vote from representatives of
the confederation's member countries in
the film Grindelwald takes possession of
a Chillin and bewitches it to choose him
as those who have seen the film can
attest to this plan doesn't quite work
out instead grindelwald's lie is
revealed by Albus and Amber Fort
Dumbledore news commander and their
allies proving that the Chillin has been
a victim of galit's dark magic at this
point galit is forced to flee the
ceremony and a different unbewitched
Chillin chooses a new leader for the
international Confederation of of
wizards to align with previously
discussed portions of this Theory at
this point Albus Dumbledore would have
still been a rival of Grindelwald as
this Theory hinges on the idea of gellet
winning his duel with Albus in 1945.
this particular ceremony for a newly
elected Supreme mugwump took place about
a decade before that in 1937. however
that doesn't mean that Grindelwald
wouldn't have tried to occupy this
position again at a later date in my
opinion if he'd wanted to become Supreme
mugwump after defeating Dumbledore in
the 1945 duel all he would have had to
do is claim the title with that in mind
though I'm not too sure he would have
cared all that much since the only
reason he was after the position in 1937
was to further his plan to reign of The
Wizarding World but if he was able to
defeat Albus and take over the world's
population of magical and non-magical
creatures alike all by sheer force why
would he need to be the elected chairman
of the international Confederation of
wizards I think it's much more likely
that he would have abolished the
international Confederation of wizards
and declared himself King as I mentioned
before conclusion if Grindelwald had
defeated Dumbledore this brings us to
the end of another video but before we
wrap up let's review shall we if Golic
Grindelwald had won the duel between
himself and Albus Dumbledore here's how
The Wizarding World would have been
impacted 1. the Great and Powerful Albus
Dumbledore would have been a dark wizard
rather than one of the good ones and he
likely would have been grindelwald's
highest ranking official and most
trusted Ally two everyone from Wizards
to Muggles would have been placed into a
hierarchical caste system with pure
blood acolyte to the top and imprisoned
disobedient Muggles at the bottom 3.
Voldemort wouldn't have been known as
the next most powerful dark wizard
comparable only two garlic Grindelwald
but instead he would have been one of
grindelwald's officials carrying out his
wishes for the greater good in the UK
before Grindelwald would have been the
world's leader having overthrown all
muggle governing bodies and conventions
as well as the international
Confederation of wizards I rather like
the idea that he would have wanted to be
known as the dark King there is one last
thing we didn't get around to discussing
if Grindelwald would have won the duel
and defeated Dumbledore what would that
have meant for our young boy Harry I
guess we'll have to tackle that in
another video let me know what you
thought of today's Theory by sharing
your thoughts in the comments below and
as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel until next time we want only
freedom freedom to be ourselves
[Music]
foreign